i remember one time i had like a bit of
hair
sticking up and for some reason when i
put like water in it it didn't go down
all right i was like [ __ ] this that's
real [ __ ] annoying
and i'm like 10 years old and i'm like
i'm just going to cut it it's in the way
because it wouldn't go down right so i
cut like a chunk of my hair out
and then i was like connor what did you
cut your hair i'm like no
no mother of course i didn't cut my hair
she's like there's a piece of mistake
i'm like i think got trapped in the door
is all i said she's like she's like
you're so you're telling me
that it got stuck in the door and it
with enough force that it pulled your
hair out and i was like of course
until she's like let's try it
i've again prayed for more in my life
that my hair gets ripped out
so you go to the door the hinge she's
like first of all she's like how did you
get your door
your head in the hinge at the end i'm
like
i have no idea so i put my hair in the
door
and i close it and of course no hair
falls out and she's like
what happened she's like okay mom uh i
cut it because it was annoying me she's
like why did you do that she's like
i don't know it didn't go down with
water that's what i normally do and
she's like
you didn't need to do that i'm like oh
okay okay [ __ ] mine started earlier when
i was like still in like nappies and
stuff like that right
yeah yeah yeah like because i had this
really for some reason i had the fear of
sitting on the toilet
for some reason like because i think
what it was because i think i was like
two or three years old right it's like
the last stage of you still wearing
nappies right yeah and like
i really hated taking a [ __ ]
like like i really like i was
really scared and i think it's because i
think my mom explained it to me earlier
later she was like i think you were
scared
not to like actually sit on the toilet
but to like flush the toilet because you
thought you were gonna get sucked in as
well
we're not gonna lie those those are
airplane toilets yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it's the airplane toilet fear and i
thought that same force was in my home
toilet as well
i had the same fear i just [ __ ]
remembered this yeah and it came from an
airplane because you know when you flush
the airplane it feels like you're gonna
get like sucked into oblivion yeah when
i was like 10 what i would do is i would
like
[ __ ] if you had like two seconds you
pressed the button and it goes two
seconds yeah
yeah yeah so like two seconds yeah so i
thought i had that in my home tour so
at that point so two three-year-old me
was just like i figured out a resolution
just don't [ __ ] just don't
just i'm wearing nappies isn't that like
a south park yeah
i'm wearing nappies i just don't [ __ ]
but
like you know at that stage as well i
was like i was too embarrassed to admit
to my parents that
i literally just shat in my nappies yeah
so
what i would do is like i would hide
behind the couch
and kind of just like subtly do it
while my parents weren't looking
and my parents and my mom would my mom
would like walk into the living room and
be like joey what are you doing
i would try and get a refund on the kid
if you're doing that it's like it's like
uh joey what are you doing and i'm just
like nothing this is like
you're pooping aren't you i'm like no
me want my face
and my mom's like i can literally smell
the [ __ ]
what are you talking about go to the
[ __ ] toilet
and i would literally do that for like
the longest time until like finally you
know you get to the stage where you have
to get out of nappies right yeah yeah
and so i'm just like for the first like
i think you prolong that as much as you
for the first like two or three months
out of nappies i dreaded
having to take a [ __ ] i'm like i had to
like psych myself being like
all right i'm not gonna get sucked in
today you can do it
it was horrible man honestly i still
have uh like
i still have a fear of going to the
tortoise on airplanes just because of
that noise like if
if i need to i don't mind it's just not
pleasant it's not pleasant yeah
it's like i just get like a small
[ __ ] flashback every time i hear that
noise i need to wear like
[ __ ] thick headphones every time i go
man
i'm turning that music off that's what
noise cancelling headphones were